you know what's the fastest way to judge
how big somebody thinks today it's their
level of urgency to execute and do
something let me give you four stories
here one story is an interaction I had
with mayor Suarez from Miami the other
one is an F-15 pilot the other one is a
lawyer from the president like
president's lawyer and last one is the
owner of a publishing house that I want
to buy today each of them reacting in a
different way but all of them are going
to give you Insight on how big that
person thinks today by the way if you
get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
today's sponsor is Aura what Aura does
is protect you against identity theft
which today it is the fastest growing
crime in all of America just last year
1.5 million Americans experience
identity theft for you know how much
money ready not 1 billion not 5 billion
not 10 billion 52 billion dollars just
last year every 14 seconds somebody's
identity is stolen which means during
this video four to five people's
identity will be stolen and the reason
why this is important to me is I've been
in the financial industry for a long
time Insurance Finance we spend a lot of
money every year to protect against
cyber security attacks just a fun fact
one of our employees Aaron went on their
website and he tested to see how many
times his identity had been stolen his
password over 40 times on the dark web
you may want to find out how many times
your identity has been stolen so if you
want to protect yourself from the
fastest growing crime in America visit
aura.com forward slash valuetainment to
start your 14-day trial one more time
Aura
aura.com forward slash valuetainment to
start your 14-day free trial with aura
try Aura free for two weeks to find that
if any of your personal information or
your family's personal information has
been compromised so last week I'm
driving
I'm coming back from Miami I get a
message mayor Suarez hey Pat love your
content want to get you to the City Hall
to get you on the podcast no problem I
said let's have our assistants talk to
each other so we can figure out a date
so they can match your calendar with
mine what's your assistance number I
send it to him Karina here's the phone
number I'm driving
I don't hear back from them I send that
message real quick while I'm driving
full disclaimer I said I'm still driving
talking to my wife
all of a sudden my assistant in the back
answers the phone hi says yes this is
Rosie oh hey Rosie hey I'd like to
schedule a time on the behalf of the
mayor blah blah blah
when I tell you the difference my wife
said seconds maybe 10 seconds
I'm like what they communicated gotta
dig in the calendar you know what's the
first thing I thought about this guy
works like I roll he works fast of
course he's a winner
because Only Winners move that quickly
when they say they're going to do
something that was a Friday he could
have said well follow up on Monday nope
like this he wants to run at the next
level maybe he's got a shot because of
how quickly he gets things done so
that's the first story let me tell you
the Second Story Second Story is a
Publishing House I want to buy they have
a niche I want to tell you the name you
know who it is but it's a niche I want
to make an offer to buy this company
I get a hold of to see on the founder I
send a message to this guy I say hey I'd
like to talk to you to see what the
vision like oh my God yeah no problem
let's get him going he's not so what's
your number he sends me the number sends
me the number I call him immediately he
doesn't pick up I send a message back
hey just called you
do you have a few minutes to jump on a
call he responds back and he says to me
uh yeah today and tomorrow very very
busy how about we do after New Year's
you guys do you realize how crazy that
is to me for somebody to say let's
they're not massive like they need more
business
let's follow up after New Year's first
thing I thought about that's probably
the culture of the company later later
not a now mentality which is another
reason why I'd love to buy the company
because we're the now mentality imagine
what we could do I'll tell you the third
story I'm talking to a fighter pilot
this fighter pile F-15 fighter pilot him
and I are having a conversation ticket I
met him 17 years ago then I met him
again at an event we were both speaking
who I'm like hey wait a minute then I
hear you speak 17 years ago yes boom
anyways he messages me comes in brings a
gift it's up there somebody gave me a
nice little helmet for pilot and we're
talking I said so where are you at right
now what phase Earth so I'm kind of
going through this decision I got to
make right now so you got to make that
decision yes like man this is a tough
time because I'm running a BPW business
planning workshop 12 hours I'm speaking
maybe more is what I'm speaking at that
the following day and I say I got
podcasts I got this I got that I got
this I got a board call I got a board
tomorrow night what do you got going on
nothing come to the house
he comes to the house tomorrow night yes
drives up we come to the house him and
his partner we're together till nine
o'clock at night then I send one of my
guys to show him the other Studio we
stayed there we talk
deal is being broken right there whether
we can do something or not I made my
offer I can't really do anything except
these offers guess what he came the next
day okay cool he knows how I work we
don't have time to watch you next week
let's go that night while I'm meeting
with him I get another call from a
lawyer from a president we got a handful
of living presidents you can pick and
choose who this lawyer is from which
president he calls hey I got your number
from this person I've seen your stuff I
said what do you got going on right now
he says I'm Boca right now I'm doing a
meeting I said why don't you come over
right so you want me to come over right
now I want you to come over right now
I'm sizing them up to see how it works
I'm busy he's busy he says uh I haven't
eaten anything so don't worry about it
I'll get you food what kind of food you
like Sushi Toro salmon belly yes no
problem I got you ready come on down he
drives and get him caviar get him this
get him down I cook I put it together
for him present it for him he sits there
one meeting leaves he stays there him
and I are together at 11 o'clock at
night talking that night I got two other
calls I got to make then I get up to go
to the office to spend 12 hours with
thousand something people that were
watching this 5 thousand people are
probably watching of a thousand people
are registered for this and we did a
business planning workshop that night
then the next day I'm on a trip to take
36 people to go watch the messy uh comp
what do you call it a tournament with
mbappe we shut down the Flemings and
then right after Flemings in uh what
city were we in Tampa we go to the
biggest Suite in Tampa we watch Joe
burrow play Tom Brady Joe bro comes back
and wins then we get on the flight with
the family come back then the next day
seven o'clock in the morning I go to
Dallas to have a meeting to make a
promotion then I come back but this is
the schedule of somebody that's got a
big Vision so you get to gauge somebody
that's on it going going going going
going versus somebody that says yeah how
about after New Year's yeah how about
after this by the way
two and a half years covet happens
whatever you want to give it March of
2020 it's been two and a half years
whatever the timeline is do you know
everybody in the private Equity space
when I would talk to let's do a zoom our
company doesn't allow us to do covert
this cover that do you know what's the
one guy that wasn't doing that the big
name his name is David Solomon you know
what company he runs Goldman Sachs you
know how many deals he picked up about
everybody else was being kicked you know
kicking back being casual he let from
the front no wonder he's a lead dog and
people follow his lead because he is
urgent go in going going and still find
stem to spend time with his family and
his kids on Thanksgiving
and all the other fun stuff that he does
and he's still a DJ by the way how crazy
is that runs the most powerful Financial
firm in the world that everybody from
that company pretty much the next step
for them is to work on their president
and he's a DJ
insane or what so question for you which
Camp are you part of
after New Year's or you're part of uh
let's get on the phone okay yes no maybe
what about this what about that which
Camp are you part of I can tell you how
big you think based on which Camp you're
part of so can everybody else big
thinkers smell and read other big
thinkers if you're urgent and want to
get things done fairly quickly you're in
a big thinkers camp
if you got all the time in the world you
ain't part of the big thinkers Camp you
get to pick and choose by the way this
may be the one thing you need to shift
going into 2023 if you got value from
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe I got a video to give you I
did seven years ago how big you think if
you've never seen this how a big thinker
thinks click here to watch that video
take care everybody bye-bye